- Very brief welcome and
introduction to this event.
The university lecture as we all know
is one of the most
important times of the year
and it's when we celebrate
our most creative minds
but it's also a time in which we celebrate
the academic way of life,
the people that we ask
to come and speak are
those who we admire most
because of what they've
contributed to the development
of knowledge and I think
I'd have to say that
right now it seems more
important to do this
than at any time I can remember
and on behalf of all of us
we're extremely grateful
to Professor Gelman
for giving us the chance both to honor him
and to affirm the world of the university
and I now turn this over
to John Coatsworth, John?
(audience claps)
- Thank you, President
Bollinger and welcome to
this evening's university lecture.
This is a night we all look forward to,
when disparate parts of
the Columbia community
have an opportunity to come together
and to learn about the academic
work of a distinguished
faculty member whose current scholarship
might otherwise remain outside our vision.
I certainly count it as a
privilege and a great pleasure
to be surrounded by so many
colleagues and students
for this good purpose.
Tonight, we will hear from Andrew Gelman.
Higgins Professor of Statistics
and professor of political science.
Professor Gelman is known
to many of you for his
public commentaries, making
use of statistical methods
to explain politics and polling.
Tonight his focus is different,
but the subject is no less
timely and compelling.
The title of his talk is The
Statistical Crisis in Science,
How to Move Forward.
Professor Gelman became a
faculty member in Columbia's
department of statistics 17 years ago
and then two years later
in 2002 he received a joint
appointment in the department
of political science.
Before arriving here, he had
received undergraduate degrees
in mathematics and physics
from MIT and had earned his
master's and PhD degrees
in statistics from Harvard.
He is the founding director
of Columbia's applied
statistics center, and
the author of a number
of highly regarded books
that have attracted readers
in both academic circles and
among the general public.
His book published in 2008,
Red State, Blue State,
Rich State, Poor State,
Why Americans Vote the Way
They Do, succeeded in
upending political myths
about partisan voting
patterns and changed the way
we think about elections
and about American politics
forever.
Professor Gelman is
something of an evangelist,
actually an evangelist for
improving the way in which
we communicate scientific
research findings to the public.
He frequently speaks about the importance
of making statistics visible
and communicating them
more effectively to the
public, a subject that is also
very much the focus of his
admired classroom teaching.
He has also maintained
his own widely read blog
for some 10 years now and is a contributor
to the Washington Post
political science blog
called The Monkey Cage.
That name, I should note,
comes from a wonderfully
resonant HL Mencken quote,
democracy is the art
of running the circus
from the monkey cage.
Professor Gelman's
interest are wide ranging.
He has at different times
focused his attention
on police stops, social
networks, public health
and redistricting.
He has received some two
dozen academic awards,
including the outstanding
statistical application award
from the American Statistical Association,
the award for the best article published
in the American Political Science Review
and the council of presidents
of statistical society's
award for outstanding
contributions by a person
under the age of 40.
As you know from listening
to President Bollinger
and from observing many
of the most exciting new
developments at Columbia,
we are increasingly focused
on bringing the university's
vast knowledge to bear
on the pressing problems of the day.
Doing so has always been
and always will be part
of our mission.
With that in mind, I want
to conclude with a quotation
from the speaker we honor tonight.
According to Professor Gelman, quote,
every field worth studying
connects to one's everyday life.
Statistics is not an isolated field.
It connects to everything.
I am sure that his talk
will leave little doubt
as to the rightness of that claim.
Please join me in welcoming
the 2017 university lecturer,
Professor Andrew Gelman.
(audience claps)
- Hi, so the other day,
somebody sent me an email.
They said, did you see this
thing, it was in the newspaper,
about stents, so a stent
is some sort of balloon
that inflates your artery and it said that
stents do no better with
placebo, but this guy said
that wasn't true, he read
the paper and actually
stents did better than
placebo, so I was curious.
So I read the article.
And it was a ...
Randomized trial where 100
patients got the stents
and 100 patients got the
sham surgery where they do
the surgery and they
don't put the stent in
which don't give me that
look because they consented
to, you know, be randomized.
It's very safe, like, there
were no adverse events
apparently and you get extra
goodies if you participate
in a medical study, they
do nice things to you
and they give extra care,
so it seems fair enough.
And there was a difference,
so the stent group
did better than the placebo group,
but not statistically
significantly better.
So they said that stents didn't work.
It's kind of funny, I'm
not really an expert
on the placebo effect, I
think that's what, like,
as a statiscian, I'm not an expert on X,
you know, for any X
that I happen to study.
And I, but I wonder
about the placebo effect
because if you know there's a 50% chance
you're actually getting the sham treatment
then I don't know if you
get, like, a 50% placebo
or what, they do, the
people who did the study
was a very professional
job, they knew what
they were doing and they
did standard good practice.
So they asked people, which
treatment do you think
you got and most people,
most people didn't know
and the ones who guessed
guessed right about 50%,
so, like, it seemed
that people didn't know
what they were getting.
Anyway, I looked at the
paper and so I realized
the analysis wasn't quite, it wasn't wrong
but they did this thing
called a Gaines Score
where they looked at improvement
from pre-test to post-test.
They didn't control for
differences in pre-test
between the groups.
If you do that, you'll get
more statistical efficiency.
So I thought maybe I could
get the raw data and analyze,
just kidding, so I, but I
was able to read the paper,
you could actually deduce
from the summary statistics
in the paper what the analysis
would be if you controlled
appropriately for the pre-test score.
So I was able to reconstruct
the analysis that
they could have done, but before doing it,
I got really excited
because I could tell from
the differences between pre and post
that when I reanalyzed it, it
would make the effect bigger
and the standard error smaller,
and it was already at P
equals .2, which isn't, like,
good enough, it's supposed
to be .05, but I knew
it would get better, so I
had to go to work, like,
I don't know, like, teach
a class or something,
I don't remember, and so ...
I quickly dashed off an
email to my colleague
at the New York Times saying,
hey, this is gonna be big,
this is great, like, so then I went back
and I was figuring it out.
And it did just what I said
except the P value went
from .2 to .09.
Which was, like, not what it's
supposed to do for the story
because it should be, it went to .04
and then I would be able to say, look,
once you do the right analysis,
it becomes statistically significant
so that you can see by
doing the right analysis,
it changes the story completely
from stents don't work to stents work.
The whole headline changes.
Everything is changed, it's all ...
We did it, statistics!
But went to .09, but then I realized
this is even a better story, really,
because what's so magic
about .05 or whatever, right?
So the real point is that yeah,
the stents did better maybe.
The difference, I don't
care if it's statistically
significant, the difference
was not clinically large.
And I think, actually, like ...
There's some issues.
I think the study was very
well done, but that's kind of
the point, I think
there's some issues here,
and I'll kind of get
back to that, but first
I just want to say it's
a pleasure to speak here.
I've taught here for 21 years
and to have a room full of collaborators,
students, family and friends,
it's really wonderful,
it's a privilege to be
at any university, but
especially this one.
And it's said that, those of
you who have taught know this,
that to truly, the only way
to truly learn a subject
is to teach it.
And I can assure you that
my students understand
statistics very well, I know
that because they've taught me
so much, and I've learned so
much from my collaborators
as well, so let me tell you a story.
This is something somebody
sent to me in the mail
a few years ago.
I think they wanted to
me to make fun of it.
Influence of Valentine's Day
and Halloween on birth timing,
but I actually liked it.
I'll show you the data here
from the published article.
They had the data, number
of babies born every day
for a 20 year period and
do you see the heart there
on the left?
And then that's Valentine's
Day, there were more babies born
and fewer the week before
and the week after,
and then do you see, isn't
that cute, the witch there?
Yeah, that's Halloween, yeah.
So it's kind of funny because,
like, not only are there
more Cesarean section
births on Valentine's Day
because what shows love more than,
but more natural births too.
Which seems kind of funny,
like, how could that be
although those of you with
statistics training will know
that selection occurs even on the things
that aren't selected
because the natural births
are all the births that weren't
induced or Cesarean sections
so in fact, you get selection there too.
Anyway, this is kind of interesting.
It's statistically significant.
You can see by those little stars.
Someone sent me a paper the other day,
it was some claim I didn't quite believe.
I looked at it really
carefully and it said
it was statistically
significant at the .1 level
which, you're not really
supposed to say but I just
threw that out for those
of you who are into jargon
like that.
If you look at this,
it's like, is this real?
You know, I'm not sure,
what should you do?
I think what we should do
is look at all 366 days
of the year, so someone
made this graph for me.
This is the benefits of collaboration.
Somebody, oh, hey, someone ...
Is this hair trigger?
Someone made this graph for me.
You can ignore the curves,
this is just the raw data.
The total number of babies
born each day of the year.
You can see fewer babies on
New Year's and July fourth
and Christmas.
There's Valentine's Day and
Halloween which, sort of like,
it's not completely clear,
do they really stand out?
You see a wiggling.
There are about 52 of those
cycles during the year.
Because it's not a 28 year period.
So there's some confounding
of day of week and date
during the year so we need to
do a little bit more analysis.
If we just look at this, it's hard to know
what's going on with
Valentine's Day and Halloween.
God this is so, okay, someone
made this graph for me
which I kind of like because
I hate it so much.
Because it's, you know, there's
a principle of statistical
graphics that graphs are comparisons
and this graph is sort of a
wonderful way of comparing
what's happening on the 21st
of every month going across
which is kind of goofy.
It also tells you more
babies are born in the summer
and early fall, but you
can see that much better
from this graph, so this
graph is kind of horrible
but I just wanted to convey that.
I thought it would be interesting
to see that not everything
we do is very helpful, actually.
(audience laughs)
Okay, so I'll tell you
the rest of that story
once we have the data for you to see.
Let me move on to the
statistical crisis in science.
I can start with an example.
You might have heard
of, someone did a study,
they looked at 50 common food ingredients
and they scoured the medical literature
and they found of those
50 food ingredients,
something like 40 had either
been discovered to cause cancer
or prevent cancer, some
of them both, actually.
Now my point here is not
that onions both cause
and prevent cancer.
But rather that there's a
problem with how medical research
is often conducted and communicated
and a problem also of
course in other fields
such as psychology,
medicine, and public health
and for example, the stents
story that I led off with.
Has this issue, like, so a study is done,
some data are collected
and then the result
is this very strong conclusion, like,
something works or it doesn't work.
It's actually kind of
funny if you think about it
because it doesn't matter
how bad your data are.
You can always say it
works or it doesn't work.
It's like a free headline.
I mean, you could just be,
like, you could have a spinner
and just generate random
numbers and that would be enough
to get that, not that
anyone would do that,
just generate random numbers.
They might have people,
but they might be measuring
something that is so noisy
that it's as bad as being random numbers.
In particular, if you
want to study things like
what causes cancer in
epidemiological studies,
that's kind of noisy because
people can get cancer
from all sorts of reasons.
So if you study a small effect,
you'll be seeing the noise
rather than the signal.
Now that's fine to see the
noise rather than the signal
if that's what you see, but the issue is
if you misinterpret it and
then go around telling people
not to eat onions.
That would be terrible.
But I'll talk a little bit
about political science
rather than psychology and medicine
because political science,
American politics,
is what I study.
There have been some,
oh, we will hear about
political science in a
moment, but now it's time
to return to the birthdays.
So my colleague Aki Veturi from Finland
fit a statistical model
to the birthday data.
And it's a decomposition.
So we start with the number
of babies born every day
between 1968 and 1988.
I'd just like to interject
here that it's really, like,
great, like, students love
if you can have an example
where you can find yourself
in the data, like you gather
data from the student,
then you plot them, like,
which data point am I, well,
a lot of you are in this data,
right, so you can find yourself
if you were born between
1968 and 1988.
There are several components.
There's a slow trend, a
fast nonperiodic component,
you kind of need all of these.
You need the slow trend
because there was a time
when having babies was less popular,
then a time when having
babies was more popular.
You need a fast non-periodic
component because there
are just things that happen,
like, people are in a good mood
and they have more babies, then
they're less in a good mood.
There's fluctuation.
We have day of week effect.
Fewer babies on the weekend,
and the day of week effect
changes over time, it
became more pronounced
as the number of scheduled births went up.
Then you see seasonal effect,
that there's more well known,
more people born at the
end of summer, early fall
and then finally the day of year effect
and this model was cool.
We did not tell the data,
we did not tell the model
to look for New Year's Day,
Valentine's Day, leap day,
so forth, our model had 366
parameters, one for each day.
Well, plus extra things for
the three floating holidays,
Labor Day, Thanksgiving and Memorial Day
and it just sort of
discovered from the data
what was going on and it
picks up, it picks up,
you see Valentine's Day
is actually interesting
because Valentine's Day is the only day
that has too many babies.
All the others have too few.
Well, that's not quite
true because December 24th
and December 26th have too many babies.
But that's because there's
a sort of principle
that the baby has to come
out at some point or another
so if you have fewer babies
one day, you have to have more
nearby, but Valentine's
Day is kind of special
so I actually really liked
that paper that found that.
Then we got more data.
This was from 2000 to
2015 and it's similar.
I want you to go back and
look at this one for a second.
Do you see the scale on
the Y axis here goes ...
I don't have control
over this thing, okay,
oh, I don't point at
that, I point over there?
No, okay.
Ugh.
Okay, if you look at what happened before,
there's just a lag between when I click,
do I have to say it?
Are you clicking for me here?
What's going on with
this, because I click,
it's like a delay.
Okay, the effects are larger than ...
Okay, this is what it was like before.
And you see, like, I
want to point on there
it's not so helpful.
If you see that, like, New
Year's, they're about at 80 or so
Then if you look at the more recent data,
the effects are larger.
Can you click to the next slide please?
Thank you.
Now they're around 60, so
there's also a lot more
induced births than there used to be.
But I actually want to
focus on something slightly
different here.
Look at what's going on around after 9/11.
Which is a less popular birthday now.
Do you see that there's a
two week period where there's
too many babies, and that
violates the baby has to come out
somewhere principle, you can't be, like,
scheduling your babies
for two straight weeks,
like, where do the babies come from?
So what's really happening
is that the sort of lump,
the positive thing that's
happening after 9/11
is not, is really not
about scheduling birth.
That's just a seasonal affect.
Now look at that seasonal curve.
Do you see how smooth it is?
Now if we go back to the previous slide,
if we go, yes.
Now you see there's like a
bump at the end of September.
So there was kind of a,
this model fit the data.
The second model kind
of fit the data well.
I'm gonna go back to the
next slide now please.
Yes, this model sort
of fits the data wrong
because it puts in this
slow change in September.
It puts it on the bottom,
and it should be really
on the third thing.
So we realized there was
a problem with our model
and we have prior information
that's not in the model.
And the information is, the
baby has to come out somewhere,
right, so our model said that every day,
all 366 days of the year,
there could be a spike.
Extra births or not enough
births, and it tries to fit it.
What we really need is
a model with ringing,
so it says there's a day
with not enough births
and the days before and after
have to have extra births
to counterbalance that,
otherwise it doesn't add up.
So we didn't put that in the model
and our first data analysis we got lucky
and it sort of worked out, but
in the second data analysis,
it didn't like discover the right thing.
And so I, there are a lot
of points of this example.
But maybe the most important is the way
that we go back and
forth between our model,
our data and our scientific questions.
We're sort of circling
through, looping back,
and the stronger the model we make,
the more we can learn when
the model doesn't fit.
Now the other relevant point
about this is it demonstrates
a principle from mathematics which is that
if you can't solve a problem,
embed it in a harder problem.
There's a well known
principle of mathematics.
If you can't prove a
theorem about prime numbers,
prove it on ideals, which
is a generalization of prime
numbers, if you can't
sum an infinite series,
then you solve the generating function.
And instead of trying to
figure out what's happening
two days out of the year,
we're gonna estimate
what's happening in all 366.
In statistics this is called
the blessing of dimensionality.
Some journalists contacted
us and they said,
what about Friday the 13th?
It's, like, well, this is just the 13th,
you can do more with Friday.
Look at the 13th, look at that.
You see?
It's kind of funny,
gives you a new insight
into Valentine's Day,
what's Valentine's Day?
That's right, it's the 14th.
So one reason Valentine's
Day is so popular
is it's sitting next to the 13th.
Now that's not the only
reason 'cause you don't see
a peak the 14th of every
month, but it doesn't hurt
to be next to the 14th if you want
to be getting extra births.
The funny thing is, this
pattern was in the data already.
This was in, if I go back
to the earlier graph,
it's there, we just didn't
notice it because we didn't know
where to look and you want to
hear something really funny,
go back, we're gonna go
back to the ugly graph.
Can you go back to the ugly graph please?
One more, one more.
Yes, stop.
Look at the 13th.
Isn't that funny?
I was, like, ooh, this graph is so stupid.
It allows you to compare
the same day of every month
like I would really want to compare the,
actually, if I had looked at this graph,
spent a little bit less
time laughing at it
and more time looking at
it, I would have seen,
hey, what about the 13th?
No kidding, it's right there, all along.
But you know, of course you'll
only see it if you look at it
right?
Okay, the statistical crisis in science.
So in political science,
we've had published papers
on, well, ovulation and voting.
Did you know that during a
certain time of the month ...
Sorry.
Sophie's making symbols at
me, I was distracted there.
Do you know that during ...
(laughs) Do you know that during
certain times of the month,
women are 20 percentage
points less likely,
more likely to vote for Barack Obama?
Actually, the published
research said that married,
single women were 20
percentage points more likely
to vote for Barack
Obama, but married women
were more likely to support Mitt Romney.
Do you know that men with
fat arms, college students
with fat arms were more likely to oppose
economic redistribution?
It was published in a research journal.
Do you know that elections are determined
by college football
games and shark attacks?
Again, this was all published.
Now these studies like
these are kind of notorious
in science now because
they fail to replicate.
Now I won't say all of those
studies fail to replicate.
Some of them fail to replicate.
Others, I'm pretty sure
they wouldn't replicate
if you were gonna bother to redo them.
Because the data are basically noise.
The data in these studies are
consistent with null effects
or more to the point, they're
consistent with effects
that are highly variable, unpredictable
and context dependent.
So I want to emphasize that
I'm not going around saying
that your hormones don't
affect how you vote.
I have no idea, I'm sure my
hormones affect how I vote.
I don't think they will
change 20% of people's votes.
I don't think they're gonna
change 2% of people's votes.
I have good reason for thinking that.
I think that the occasional
person might be so pissed off
that their college
football team loses a game
that they may vote a different way.
I don't expect to see a
systematic effect of that size.
I'm not gonna go around
saying effects are zero,
but I think effects are highly variable.
Now I'm gonna get back to
the sort of political point
of studies like that.
But I want to emphasize that
these problems aren't just,
like, with joke studies,
like ovulation and voting
or fat arms or whatever.
They're also in serious research.
So for example, there was a study done
about 25 years ago that
was recently published.
It was a study on an intervention
for four year old children
in Jamaica, they had 130
kids and half of the kids
got a certain educational
intervention with their mothers
at the age of four and
half of them didn't.
Now it only got published
recently because they followed
them up for 20 years and
they recorded their earnings
once they were grownups and
they found that the kids
who had the intervention
had 42% higher earnings
than the kids without the intervention.
Now 42%'s pretty good.
In fact, not only was it a large number
but it was statistically significant.
To be statistically significant,
you have to be at least two
standard errors away from zero.
A standard error is a
measure of uncertainty.
And so the standard error
of this study was about
20 points.
So what that means is ...
What does that mean?
Well, that means that they
couldn't have seen an estimate
of less than 40% or it wouldn't
have been statistically
significant and it wouldn't
have been published.
So here's, if this is zero,
and this is one standard error
which is 20% effect, any
effect estimate had to be
at least plus 40 or minus
40 or it wouldn't have been
published, so when they
said it was not only
statistically significant,
it was also large,
it was statistically
significant, it had to be large.
Now let's just suppose.
Well, I'll say this study
had some various data issues
which I'm not going to go into here.
Some of the kids left Jamaica.
The kids who left Jamaica
actually had higher earnings
than the ones who didn't leave Jamaica.
More kids in the treatment
group left Jamaica
than in the control group.
There were different
missing data, that's okay.
That always happens.
Let me ask you this.
What if the true effect was 5%?
That would be pretty good.
If you could do an
intervention for four year olds
and then 20 years later,
their incomes are 5% higher,
that would be great.
Well, if the estimate were 5%,
then the published estimate
from this study has to be
at least eight times larger
than the true effect.
Well, then you might
say, well eight times,
that's kind of too bad,
but at least they got
the direction right, but
I don't know that they got
the direction right.
What if the true effect was minus 5%?
Well, that's silly, how could it hurt
to do an intervention?
Well, you can imagine.
They thought, you know,
well, we're all set.
We don't need to do X, Y,
and Z 'cause we're getting
the intervention, I don't know.
Maybe it hurts, because after
all, if they spent an hour
a week or two hours a week doing this,
maybe they were doing that
instead of doing something
more useful, right, with their time.
Opportunity cost, right,
we've heard about that.
What if the true effect were minus 5%?
Well, the estimated effect
will still have to be at least
40%, so it could be too
high by a factor of eight
in the wrong direction, even.
Now we call this the
statistical significance filter.
It leads to systematic
overestimates of effect sizes.
It's one of these things
that everybody knows
and people don't know,
so they call these things
unbiased estimates, even
though they can be eight times
higher than the true effect,
but it's a little bit
worse than this because
there's a feedback loop.
And the feedback loop goes as follows.
I'm designing a new study.
So how large should my study be?
So I have to have a sense of
how large could the effect be,
so I look in the literature
and the literature says,
oh, this treatment has an effect of 40%.
Oh, this is a pretty big effect.
I guess if my study is this big,
I'm very likely, I have a high power,
I'm very likely to discover
something in the future.
So then someone designs their new study
being completely sure that their new study
is almost definitely gonna succeed.
Because they think they're
looking for this big effect.
Then they do the new study and ...
The data look kind of noisy
and they manage to find
something statistically significant,
but of course they do,
because they knew ahead
of time the study was gonna work, right,
so you get into this loop.
The winner's curse, they
say in economics, right?
You win the auction and
by winning, you lose.
Well, I want to write a paper sometime
called death of a
paradigm and in this case
the paradigm is a
statistical paradigm in which
you come up with an idea, you
study it, you do an experiment
you test it, you find out it's
statistically significant,
and you publish the result
and that affects policy
and the trouble is, there are
not so many low hanging fruit
around anymore, they've
been plucked already.
Indeed, in medical research,
it's considered unethical
to estimate large effects,
usually, because in medical
research you're supposed to
compare to the best available
alternative, the only
reason they could compare
stents to placebo
because they were pretty,
they had a sense that maybe stents weren't
particularly effective.
So we're actually always
studying small effects.
We're studying small
effects but we're using
statistical approach
that's designed to study
large effects and it's not working.
Now at this point, I
think the natural attitude
of the statistician would be to say,
well, obviously people should
take more statistics classes.
Maybe statistics should be a requirement
for more undergraduate majors.
Maybe we need more faculty lines.
Here I have the president
of the university here.
I can really make the case for that.
Actually, though I think that ...
Scientists have been
listening to us all too well.
They've been listening to our message
and our message is that
you can use statistics
to extract signal from noise,
that you can win repeatedly.
Even my own statistics
books have this flavor.
Which is here are some
problems, here are some data,
here's the result, I have
a 95% confidence interval.
It excludes zero, I've learned something.
Another win for statistics.
Over and over again.
That's the message that we sell.
We are telling people
what they want to hear.
I had this article with a
colleague, called the triple A
trench of subprime science
and the idea was that
just as in with the
triple A mortgage bonds,
that there's all these data
and the researchers scoop out
the statistically significant
results that flowed up
and then they collect them
and they put them together
into statistically
significant meta analyses
and it's all just kind of froth
but they get things that
are, like, the triple A bond
which is P equals .0005, and
then that's supposed to be
really valuable, but it's really
not necessarily so valuable
Now for decades, for nearly
a century, statisticians
have been patiently
training the world, people,
on how we can extract signal
from noise, like polling, right
Hundreds of millions of
voters and yet a survey
of 1500 people can tell you about them.
It's counterintuitive, right,
that you can learn about the
effectiveness of a treatment
from a randomized experiment on 20 people.
Yes, under controlled
conditions this works.
Casinos really do make money.
The theorems are not false.
But.
The theorems are only as
good as their assumptions.
How would it work if you ran a casino
and the probabilities on the dice varied
based on whether the dice were hot or cold
or who was throwing the
dice or whether the person,
whether the person sitting
next to the dice thrower
was making a face at the
person throwing the dice
or whether people knew
that they were supposed
to get high numbers or low numbers,
if there were any other
information leakage?
All of a sudden, your
casino might make money,
it might lose money, but the
modeling would have to be
a lot more difficult, so I
think we have to recognize
that we, statisticians, have
been selling, we've been
selling statistics as a form
of uncertainty laundering
and maybe we shouldn't be doing that.
So what then to do?
Well, remember the lesson
from the birthday problem
which is when the problem gets too large,
embed it in a larger problem,
when it becomes too difficult,
embed it in a larger problem.
So here's an example from
one of our collaborative
research projects.
This was a survey that I
did with some colleagues
at Microsoft research using
the X-Box video game platform
and this was done in September
and October and November
of 2012, you had the
ability to click and vote.
And 300 thousand people did so.
Here were the data.
You can see, from the
graph that in September
Obama and Romney were very close.
The number of people with
no opinion went down,
Romney took an early lead and kept going
and at the end we ended
up with President Romney
and I'm sure that we can all
agree that that wouldn't be
the worst possible outcome.
(audience laughs)
Well, that's not what happened, though.
Something went wrong.
It's almost as if people
who play the X-Box aren't
a representative sample of voters.
(audience laughs)
We can compare, they
actually fit with ethnicity
pretty well, X-Box players
are more young people,
play the X-Box, and there
are some other differences.
X-Box players are slightly more
Republican, less Democratic
which is why Mitt Romney was
winning among the X-Box players
so well, it turns out, I don't
want to spend too much time
on the example, but
I'll tell you one thing
that although the data are not so great,
not representative, we can
adjust them and learn a lot
and one reason is because
whether you play the X-Box,
you're not selecting on
people's political attitudes.
I wouldn't use an X-Box
survey to answer questions
like what video game platform
do you play, for example,
and I wouldn't use a survey
on Fox News to estimate
people's political attitudes,
but this kind of worked.
I show this slide only
because like why are we doing
polling on the X-Box,
well, let's be honest,
it was a publicity stunt for Microsoft,
but it's not like conventional
polling is so great.
Conventional polling's falling apart.
Non response rates are over 90%.
As if current trends
continue, non response rates
will soon be in the hundreds.
(audience laughs)
So it's, like, no, you
can't stand still, right?
Okay, so we adjusted the
X-Box poll for demographics.
We shifted based on their
ethnicity and their age
and so forth and then you
get this estimate over time
where Obama was ahead,
then Romney was ahead
and then Obama won, this is
very close to what you would
get from something like pollster.com
although it's kind of
impressive because each dot
is data from a separate day.
This is not a running average.
It's actually the data, it's pretty cool.
We could do better, though,
because in this poll we also asked people,
are they a Democrat, a
Republican, or an Independent,
and we asked how they voted
in the previous election
and we can also adjust for
that because the poll had
too many Republicans.
And after you do that,
you get the dark line here
so the light line is what
you got from just adjusting
for demographics, so by
adjusting for partisanship,
that actually gets rid of more
than half of the variation
over time.
What this tells us, I
mean, we went through a lot
to try to interpret this, but
I think what this tells us
is that most of the variation in the polls
is due to differential non response,
so when your candidate is not doing well,
you don't really want
to respond to the poll
and so your candidate does
even less well in the poll,
and when your candidate's doing well,
they're like yeah, I'll
play the polling game,
this is fun, yeah, how's my guy doing?
Let's check, let's check again, let's see,
is my guy still ahead,
this is great, this is fun.
And so this exaggerates
swings in true public opinion.
Now what's going on here
is that 60% of people vote
but less than 10% of people
participate in polls.
So answering a survey is optional.
And whether you answer a survey
depends a lot on your mood.
So this is kind of an amazing example
because not only did we do
better than conventional polls
but we learned something new
and it all kind of fits together.
And again, as with the birthday example,
it fits together 'cause
we're looking at more things.
If I had just studied one
day and tried to adjust it
perfectly, I wouldn't have learned.
We wouldn't have learned from that.
This was just from 2016.
This was a graph where
each dot was a poll.
Alan Abramowitz, a political
scientist, sent this to me.
Each dot is a poll, and he's
plotting the percent support,
the margin in favor of
Hillary Clinton in the poll
versus the percent of
people who said that they
were Democrats in the
survey, and it's, like,
look at this perfect correlation.
On surveys with more
Democrats, Hillary did better,
so it's still happening.
Okay, now where does this lead us?
We're in a world of big data, okay?
Big data are typically
convenience samples,
not random samples, they're
observational comparisons,
not controlled experiments.
They're available data,
they're not measurements
designed for a particular study.
So as a result, when analyzing
big data like the X-box poll
or modern public health
data, we need to adjust,
we need to extrapolate
from sample to population.
We need to match the treatment
group to the control group
'cause it's not a randomized experiment.
We need to generalize from observations
to underlying constructs of interest.
The big data need big models.
Nowadays I spend a lot of
time with my colleagues,
some of whom are in this
room, working on Stan,
which is our computer program
that fits Bayesian models.
It's named after Stanislav
Ulom, who was a 20th century
physicist who with his
colleagues developed
the so called Monte Carlo
method for solving math problems
using random simulation and ...
It's like we have this
big computer program
that fits big models.
The most important aspect
of a statistical method
is not what it does with the
data but what data it uses
and so the important part of a big model
is that it's big enough to
allow you to put the data in.
This afternoon, my department
chair Richard Davis
came by, he said, you're giving this talk.
He said, don't forget to plug statistics.
And say how important.
So I was thinking about that.
So math, I'll talk about
math, but, like, mathematics
plays three roles in this story.
The first is it's a
substitute for replication.
It's a substitute for data.
Someone does a study and I
can say, looking at the math,
don't bother replicating this
study, it's not gonna work,
it's all noise, I can see.
You know, your effect
is no more than this big
and your standard error is this big,
so math is a substitute for data.
That's probably its most
important role in statistics.
Second, we use mathematical
models for variation.
How we did stuff like
that birthday example
or the X-box, we have models.
You can't just stare at
the data and do that.
Finally, we need a lot of math
to make the computing work.
So to actually fit the
models we want to fit
requires a lot of research.
There's two things I wanted
to mention before closing
and one is the folk theorem
of statistical computing
which is that when you have a
problem with your computation
typically there's a
problem with your model.
When your computer is
running slow, there's often
something that went
wrong, that you did wrong.
And now again, like, it's,
I'm sort of mentioning
that like a little bit of
what it feels like to do what we do.
The other thing that I
wanted to say was that,
about these political
studies, claims that voters
are affected by little
things, strange things like
sporting events and shark attacks,
a claim that voters are
shallow is very popular
on the left and on the right.
And on the left you can say,
well, voters are so shallow,
the system is a sham.
On the right, it can be
used to discredit democracy
and say, well, gee, if
we don't trust voters,
we should diminish the political sphere,
get rid of taxes, 'cause
we don't trust democracy.
And I don't think that's right.
And I say that kind of as a statistician.
I think a lot of these
claims that have been made
have been made based on very noisy data.
People have set themselves
up to find effects
so they look to find
something and they find it
and in that world, every
nudge has a large effect.
And that does not actually
seem to describe the world
as I see it, and that X-box example showed
how all these swings
that you see in raw data,
when you look at them
carefully, there's actually
a lot more stability.
So in summary, I want to close with ...
I want to close with these words here.
(audience laughs)
That's all.
(audience claps)
- Thank you Andrew for a brilliant talk
and an entertaining one as well.
The floor is open to questions.
There are microphones in the aisles.
If you would step there
and just identify yourself
and then shoot your question to Andrew
and I should say before we begin
that there is a reception
in Andrew Gelman's honor
that will be taking
place in the faculty room
which is just behind the stage here
and you are all invited.
- Hello, thank you.
My name's Glen Chadler, I'm a
biomedical engineering student
and I was very interested
in what you said about
the stent and placebo study.
And how you reconstructed
the data to obtain
a different P value from the results
and so my question is,
since so much of medical
research is based on this
idea of drug versus placebo
and before and after
effects, why is there is not
a standard for medical
research so that given
a certain set of data, all researchers
would obtain the same P value?
- I don't think that P
value is so important,
so I think that we should be moving toward
a framework of continuous
quality improvement
which is an idea that's
been around in industry
since the 1920s, has been
very popular in the Japanese
auto industry for many decades.
I think the model, medical research,
I think the model should
not be we have this isolated
thing which works.
I think we should be
talking about continuing
process improvement in which ...
I believe that the doctors
and patients who are
trying out these methods
should be more active
participants and so the point is that
a stent is not an abstract thing.
People are doing it for a reason
and I think that there
should be in the ideal world
more experimentation and data collection
at the level of the individual patient,
moving away from this sort of ...
You know, Fordian idea of
there being a single thing
that's done for everybody.
In that case, the P value
is kind of irrelevant.
- [Glen] Thank you.
- Dr. Gelman, thank you so
much for your wonderful talk.
I'm a medical student and
as someone transitioning
to residency next year, stent
problem was well received.
I wanted to ask you,
how do we fix polling?
Obviously a tough question,
but I wanted to get
your thoughts on it.
There's a well known
event that happened about
a year ago where we got things wrong
and Virginia was I think
another interesting example
where the polls were off.
- How do we fix polling?
Well, you wouldn't want
polling to be too good, right?
I mean, in the sense that
voters do get to change
their mind before the election.
The 2016 national polls were pretty good.
There were certain state
polls that didn't do so well
because they didn't do enough adjustment.
They weren't all adjusting
for people living,
like, for education or urban/rural.
It's a funny thing about state polls.
That a state poll is ...
As expensive as a national
poll 'cause surveying
1500 people just costs the same amount.
But the people who do state polls,
there's a lot less money
to be made in a state poll
'cause the market is
smaller, so what do I think
is a solution?
I think the solution is
to use the national polls
and use partial pooling,
Mr. P, to estimate
state level opinion
from the national polls.
- Over here.
- Hi, my name is Amir,
really enjoyed your talk.
A very related question, but
near the end of your talk
you mentioned about
voluntary response bias
and especially things
with like an X-box poll
and on campus, you know, there
are these polls all the time.
When someone is designing
these types of polls
or surveys, what should they have in mind
from the outset to try
to eliminate that bias
before they have to take into
account all those variables?
- I think the number one
thing is you should think of
the people who respond to your polls
as your research partners.
Don't think of them as, like, you know,
like animals that you're measuring.
Think of them as, like, participants,
so figure out, like, what you want to know
from them and how you can ask it
and how they can help because conditions
when someone's responding to
a poll in the first place,
they probably want to help you.
One reason why people, like, I mean,
yeah, so I think you
want to take advantage of
that resource and that's
tended to be wasted.
Traditionally what people
do is they do a poll
and they're, like, hey,
we tricked somebody
into answering our survey,
now let's bombard them
with a bunch of questions.
But I think especially
in a particular area,
like, not in an election
poll but something
you're personally working
on, you can get a lot
out of showings some respect
for your survey participants.
- [Man] Thank you.
- Hi, professor, so you
linked in your blog.
A paper that questioned the ...
Validity of confidence
intervals and standard errors
and in that paper they
pointedly say that we shouldn't
try to interpret standard
errors because that's, like,
to draw inference from
statistics because that's
essentially applying a Bayesian framework,
so without getting too technical,
when we read papers, should we be assuming
that the standard errors are close enough
to what the Bayesian alternative would be,
or should we take these
with more grains of salt?
- Well, I usually would
interpret the results
as inferences based on certain
conventional assumptions.
So the conventional
assumption, like, if we take
the Jamaica study, the early
childhood intervention,
the conventional assumption
is the affect could be
anywhere from, like, minus
infinity to plus infinity
and if it could be anywhere in that range,
this is what you can learn.
If you then say, well,
actually, realistically
I think the effect is
probably less than 10%,
then that will change the interpretation
of these statements, so in some sense
the problem is not with
the standard error,
it's what people do
with the standard error.
- [Man] Okay, thank you.
- Hi, my name is Charles,
I'm a PhD student
in the statistics department
and I want to pick up on
something you said at the
beginning of your talk,
which was my specialty is
X and there's no such X
and it seems that in light
of the statistical crisis
the reaction has been,
well, scientists need
to learn more statistics,
they need to be more familiar
with the method, and I'm
wondering, well, how much
does it go the other way,
how much do statisticians
need to learn more
science and has there been
initiatives in that direction?
- Well, I typically feel
that every statistician
is an expert in at most
one subject so I really am
an expert on American politics,
I know something about that,
but, like, everything
else, like toxicology
or the other things I'm
working on, I'm kind of
winging it, but, you know,
there aren't that many
statisticians, there's a
lot more of other people.
So even if, I mean, if every statistician,
I mean it is good for every
statistician to be an expert
in some area, but that's
somehow kind of not enough.
But again, I think the
original sin in statistics
was this idea that we can
get strong conclusions
from any data and we have to avoid that,
so we have to, I mean,
as statisticians, I think
we have to stop doing that to people
before worrying about what to do next.
- Hi, very much thank
you for this last quote
'cause I think it's
very meditative somehow.
So I wonder why do we need
to reduce the variation,
but especially in
statistics, you want to have
the variation data for
you to reveal relations,
to show the result relations, but then
why don't you want the variations, I mean,
and use that, I think something
that you can apply that
for your state of mind,
is that, you know ...
- I think you have to
sort of separate yourself
from the data, okay, so
data have variations.
There's variation in the data.
We do the study on the
stents and we measure
how long people can exercise
and it's a noisy measure
but I think that probably
what you really want
to be doing is getting
better measurements.
Doing comparisons within
people, like getting multiple
measurements, like on the
X-box survey, people responded
multiple times so we could
have information on people
changing their opinion
and I think a lot of,
we're often, researchers
are trapped in the data.
And one thing, this
is, remember I told you
about this feedback loop
where people overestimate
the effect size, it gives
them overconfidence,
then they do the next study,
well, another problem of that
is it's kind of, when it's
too easy to, like, win,
like that, there's not much
of a motivation to work hard
and get good data and so like anything,
you're doing a study,
what's the ultimate effect,
whether people live or die,
okay, well that's great,
but a lot of things cause
people to live or die
so your data are gonna be very noisy.
You'll probably want to get
some intermediate measurements
and I think ...
There's kind of a negative
message and a positive message
I have and the negative message is that
it's too, it can be sort of
too easy to fool yourself
and even worse to fool other
people with noisy data.
So the idea of the negative
messages, either I don't want
to do that 'cause I don't
want to do bad science,
I want to, you know, I want
to discover real things,
not fake things or,
like, well, I don't want
to publish stuff like that,
I don't want to do stuff
like that 'cause in the
future it's gonna get rejected
by a journal 'cause
it's not pre-registered.
Whatever it is.
Then there's a motivation
to stop doing that,
but then how do you do things right?
Then you have these examples
where we fit big models
to the big data but you
shouldn't think of the data
as just sitting there being noisy.
It's your job to get non
noisy data or to measure
what you want to measure
or to try to do that.
- [Woman] So one more
question do you meditate?
Do you meditate?
- Oh, no, this is the
serenity prayer, associated
with Alcoholics Anonymous
and I just altered it
slightly because ...
- Because it aligns with.
- Because it struck me that this idea,
the variation, I mean, we do ...
I mean, I think that it just
seemed like it was perfect,
so that's why I did
that slight alteration.
- Andrew, you are now my model for someone
who can keep his cool in the
face of recalcitrant technology
Thank you for a brilliant
lecture, thank you for
an entertaining lecture,
and thank you for dealing
with the Powerpoint that didn't cooperate.
- Can I just, before you say
goodbye, I want to tell you
a story because probably
the best talk I ever gave
was when I was speaking at MIT
and I was giving a talk
on statistical graphics
and the power went out
and it was on graphics
and so we were just talking.
We had a whole conversation about graphics
without using any graphs,
and it was great, you know,
so you don't need technology,
you can't rely on it.
- Thank you very much.
You're all invited to our reception.
(audience claps)